[Applause]
[Music]
yes
happy wednesday everyone it is wednesday
another glorious day in the people's
republic of biden
where every day the great unifier leads
us down a path of chaos but before we
dive in it's time for seven jokes not to
be confused with the cnn lineup
greg seven jokes
[Music]
i do not like that music anyway a
florida teacher has been arrested for
having sex with a student in her car on
multiple occasions when asked about it
she said it wasn't sex she was showing
the kid how to drive a stick
[Laughter]
she's been fired although there's a
school-wide petition demanding she still
teach driver's head
that's two
katie kirk is getting called a
misogynist for her new memoir in which
he trashes other women and glasses over
a connection to perverts like matt lauer
and jeffrey epstein defenders say that's
unfair and point out to her charity work
for the ted pundi foundation
when told she was being called a
misogynist by other woman
she replied tell those [ __ ] to shut
up and make me a sandwich
that's four
you're counting at home
actress slash comedian slash has been
sarah silverman
slams hollywood for casting non-jewish
actors to play jewish characters as an
example of jew face
which is the kind of nuanced opinion
you'd expect from a performer who's done
this
vice president kamala harris has finally
sold her dc condo for 1.85 million the
bad news for kamala according to a new
democratic bill the new buyer owes her
nothing because the condo will pay for
itself
meghan trainor and her husband admitted
to having two toilets next to each other
so they can go to the bathroom at the
same time
whereas the extra toilet in brian
stelter's bathroom is a spare
and that's seven jokes
i give it four out of seven maybe three
all right so what happened to all those
progressive women who once cared about
women especially women in power well it
all goes away if you aren't their kind
of woman suddenly oppression is
necessary
here's our favorite sack of spoiled
potatoes
joy behar explaining that activists had
to go into the bathroom to confront
senator cinema
cinema is m.i.a all over the place she's
not around they call her to have a
meeting they try to get her on the phone
she doesn't she's you know she's like a
missing person so this is the only
alternative they have
easy for her to say
no one's brave enough to follow joy
behar into the can
[Laughter]
talk about a death wish
six feet of distance versus that blast
radius
the only time i'd agree with fauci about
wearing multiple masks
so okay cinema being m.i.a makes it okay
for her to be bullied in a bathroom by
joy's logic right-wing activists should
be in a line 15 deep in front of a stall
when kamala is dropping the kids off at
the pool
an old phrase
i mean talk about someone being m.i.a
she's the first vp in history who can
only be found with an amber alert
but my favorite hypocrite the
shapeshifter kirsten powers who used to
spend many a lonely night lecturing us
on how mean we are to women in politics
and that a lack of grace was destroying
the very fabric of america but now that
she's on cnn her opinion suddenly
changes it's amazing what 300 bucks a
week and free hair and makeup will do
i don't know if that's the case she
claims that she was flabbergasted
flabbergasted that people were upset
over bullies chasing cinema into the
stall and her reasoning was if cinema
didn't want them to follow her into the
bathroom she shouldn't have gone into
the bath
damn all that's missing is she was
asking for it
yes how dare the senator use a bathroom
and how dare she show off her
well-rounded moderate answers for the
world to see
and why and why the need to use the
toilet just do what other democrat
senators do and piss on our constituents
so
so it's a tale thank you
it's a tale of two kirstens one denied a
safe space in a restroom and the other
crapping on the idea of common decency
sorry powers there's a time and a place
for people to make demands and it's not
in the ladies room trust me i've tried
more important here you have power
shaming a woman for needing the bathroom
while excusing bullying tactics of the
left this from a woman who once said
quote in our pugilistic take no
prisoners era preaching grace toward
those on the other side of the political
fence is decidedly
culture
yeah that's one of power's quotes about
grace
turns out she's about as graceful as
biden on a stair climber
one thing is for certain she's got the
mob behind her the bullying of cinema
was cheered on on twitter
but you think those who preach grace
would challenge the mob rather than
handing them the pitchforks that's
hardly christ-like but once politics
poisons minds you have idiots justifying
all sorts of extremism it's a spectrum
from confronting people at dinner to
physically attacking them we called it
antifa but they called it an idea
meanwhile angry moms and dads are
treated like they're placing ieds in the
faculty parking lot the double standard
is as palpable as the stench in a
capitol hill men's room
take kelly paul wife of rand paul
writing quote a mob held us hostage for
10 minutes spitting on us and
threatening to kill us no charges fake
anthrax and death threats sent to our
home no charges now just learn the
person who called rand's senate office
threatening to shoot us will not be
charged i wonder if kirsten powers
thinks she had it coming hey if you
didn't want to be threatened with death
maybe just stay out of the limelight you
know return to the kitchen keep your
mouth shut it's so very taliban it's
amazing how much the female left have in
common with those lady haters and i'm
not even talking about their sandals or
beards
they both share the delight in coercion
as a means to silence uppity women the
taliban will stone a woman for showing
an inch of ankle the left will berate a
politically moderate woman for showing
an ounce of gumption if there were any
more taliban biden would be sending them
weapons
her parents came this close to naming
her bmw american conservative union
foundation senior fellow mercedes
slapped
he grew up on a raisin farm and tonight
he's raising our iqs senior fellow at
the hoover institution and author of the
great new book the dying citizen victor
davis hanson
he's like a discount martini dry and
full of cheap gin
westernrazer.com owner
david angelo
when she gives blood it's served on the
rocks with a salted rim fox news
contributor cat tim
all right before i get to you victor i
got to get some out of the way here dave
when you were last on the show you were
the spokesman for this razor company and
now you kind of like worked your way up
the ladder now you're the owner in like
a couple of weeks so i'm beginning to
think that this isn't a company this is
you with a p.o box
well we do have a p.o box
we get so much fan mail from satisfied
customers who visit westernrazer.com
that we just had to expand capacity
thank you for pointing that out you
couldn't hunt you couldn't hire somebody
else to be the owner and you're the
owner and spokesman it's just you
and one razor you only have one razor
no there's many razors and they're all
available now at westernrazer.com
greg i appreciate you challenging it
these are the this is the caliber of
guests that i get even at leading late
night thank god victor you're here to
save us from this evil man
we're seeing this weird trend where we
are decriminalizing crime and
criminalizing basic citizens or basic
decency you have been talking about this
and writing about this for years what is
going on
well there is one consistency and it's
power and ideology so when i was 50
years ago i was a student
and we all heard any means necessary and
that was france fannin says this and
sartre says this and malcolm x and then
it was the ends justify the means kind
of a watered-down machiavelli so
whether they swarm rand paul or whether
schumer goes outside the court with a
mob and says we're coming after you
gorsuch that's okay
and it's uh okay to go after cinema yeah
but it's not okay if you're a
conservative and there is a consistency
because
people with superior morality feel that
the means are justified because their
ends are so much more noble they're
intellectual they're
enlightened and the rest of us the drags
the chumps the clingers
we just
do what they tell us and that's that's
the consistency it's ideology and power
of the left they don't believe in a
principle or consistency
and they've been pretty effective about
it greg yeah it's true because it seems
to be growing and it is it goes back to
that old adage and i i don't know if it
was krauthammer but it was the
we think they're wrong
they think we're evil right and they
that justifies whatever they do is if i
think mercedes is evil i can follow you
into the bathroom but you know you're
not getting farther i don't think you
can follow me i might have to kick you
with my boot okay wearing a boot yeah no
boots cameraman if you can grab that i
mean don't actually literally grab it
what's going on with the uh the feminist
women that are all girl power until it's
somebody i mean this cinema isn't even a
republican no but she might want to
convert cinema might want to say you
know what i'm done with these democrats
it's appalling that not only the
democrat women won't support cinema in
this case and that they allow for this
bullying behavior mind you they
criticize donald trump for bullying
behavior yet they themselves are
adopting this bullying behavior and
wasn't joe biden supposed to come in and
bring decency yeah and morality back to
the white house
and he's allowing for this to occur and
not defending cinema i think it's been
an outrage he's building bullies better
i like that
that just came to me
see david that david that came to me
that's why i'm here and you're there
selling razors
we need a copywriter like you greg you
should come join the team do you have
any openings yeah i could work sometimes
where would i have the job interview
uh we can we can arrange you're hired
greg you're hired right here you're
hired
i'll send you uh what is it a 10.99
whatever
who cares at this point it's off the
books
just under the table yes i get paid i
get paid for every razor you sell
all right you have a thought on this
topic i'm sure you do you're a smart guy
yes
well you know i saw the the video yes
i've seen him in the bathroom and you
know this big confrontation but actually
was good that happened because
you know cinema she's angered the
democrats and that was the bathroom that
hillary chose to assassinate her in
and thankfully they brought the camera
and she didn't have an opportunity saved
hillary was in the next stall with a
piano wire
he was just like
ruined
saved her life that's it you know no
one's talked about that
she couldn't she that activist saved
kirsten cinema's life that's the thing
we always gotta look for the other
angles yes yes
and
like the angles on a face need a really
good shaver thank you greg i appreciate
it that's why that's why you're our
number one copywriter yes i have a hard
time with my adam's apple i always get
that little extra i can't get rid of it
i don't know what to do i'm considering
a total gender change
cat
so
you're a woman and congratulations thank
you yes
thank you i am yes where are where do
you where are you when you see when you
see people like kirsten or joy saying
that it's okay to treat certain women
this way but you better not do it to me
obviously right i mean the jezebel
article about it was so interesting
because i
it's okay to bully you know uh kirsten
sit him in the bathroom i researched i
researched this okay i did some research
i typed in
um street harassment catcalling into
jezebel.com there's like 170 articles
about how bad it is for people to
comment on your body when you're walking
yeah you would think that they would
also think it's bad for people to
comment on your character while you're
pooping yes like
you
think those would go together but you'd
be wrong i know uh and i am not someone
who you know worries too much about
social norms i think that they hold us
back but the one where people don't
follow you in the bathroom and film you
i like that that's a good one
yeah i don't i don't want to
decriminalize that yeah no she serious
she better worry you know if she takes
too long to you know respond to an email
yeah that's what she asked for said it's
okay yep not okay excellent point all
right thank you you're welcome
that was so unnecessary hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else